There's quite a lot about the ethics of
the way they treat non human animals.
I say non human,
because of course we are.
Animals were not plowed,
so I thought fun guy went up.
Bacteria,
we all,
we all animals.
Um,
there is uh,
a double standard,
uh,
in our ethics of precedent,
which place,
which builds a wall around our own
species,
Homo Sapiens,
which is rather odd evolutionary,
or you could think about the fact that
we are close cousins of chimpanzees.
We think about the fact that we are
descended from a common ancestor that
lived only about six or 7 million years
ago.
If you want to erect a moral wall around
our species and say,
for example,
that a human embryo,
even a very beginning human embryo a
long before it develops,
the nervous system is somehow worthy of
moral consideration than an adult
chimpanzee.
Then that is a rather evolutionary
viewpoint.
If you look back in our ancestry,
at what point would you draw the line?
Would you give?
If there were Australopithecus answer's
almost certainly our ancestor
Australopithecus of 3 million years ago.
If you were to meet what if wanted,
survived in the African jungle when you
give it the same moral consideration as,
as the rest of us,
or would you say?
No,
no,
that's what has the same moral
consideration as a chimpanzee.
Um,
if we look back in history a couple of
centuries ago,
most people accepted slavery and,
uh,
nowadays,
of course that's a horrifying thought.
No,
we don't.
No civilized person today except
slavery.
And if you look back further,
still,
we had the appalling things that the
Romans were doing in the coliseum with,
with spectator sport,
watching people killing other people,
lions,
killing people regarding it as fun
entertainment to take the children not
to.
We're certainly getting better as steven
pinker has said in his book,
the better angels of our nature and
Michael Shermer has in his book on the
moral Argh.
Um,
so we're changing a lot and it's there
for sort of fairly obvious thing to do,
to look into the future and say,
what will our future descendants think
when they look back at us?
The way we look back at our slave owning
ancestors with horror,
what will our descendants will look back
on it in our time,
and I think the obvious candidate would
be the way we treat non human animals.
Uh,
my view would be that we want to avoid
suffering.
Therefore,
the criterion would be,
can this creature suffer?
This is the criteria.
And that Jeremy Bentham,
the great moral philosopher laid out,
uh,
Kevin,
can they suffer?
There's every reason to think that
mammals,
at least,
uh,
I'm probably many more cans,
can suffer perhaps as much as we can
pain.
Think about what pain is for
biologically speaking.
Pain is a warning to the animal.
Doesn't do that.
Again,
if the animal does something which is
which results in pain,
that is a kind of ritual death.
It's telling the animal.
If you do that again,
you might die and you might fail to
reproduce.
That's why not for selection has built
pain into our nervous system,
was built the capacity to feel pain into
our nervous system.
So don't mess around with a whole nuts
because it's painful.
Don't do that again.
Don't pick up burning coals from the
fire.
Don't do that again.
There's absolutely no reason as far as I
can see why a nonhuman animal,
a dog or a chimpanzee or a cow should be
any less capable of feeling pain than we
can.
When you think of what pain is actually
doing,
pain feels like something primitive
feels like something like seeing color
or smelling a rose or something like
that.
It doesn't feel like the kind of thing
for which you need intellect and
actually you can go even further than
that.
You might say,
since pain is there to warn the animal,
not to do that.
Again,
an animal which is a slow learner and
animal which is not particularly
intelligent,
might actually need more intense pain in
order to deter it from doing that.
Again,
then a human who is intelligent enough
to learn quickly not to do that again,
so it's.
It's even possible that nonhuman animals
are capable of feeling more intense pain
than we are.
I'm not sure how far I want to push that
argument,
but I think at least I can say this
absolutely no reason to suppose that
they feel less pain than we do,
and we should give them the benefit of
the doubt.